con gases lacrimógenos y violencia así
es como la policía turca ha reprimido
esta misma tarde una manifestación en el
centro de estambul por el día de la
internacional de la eliminación de la
violencia contra las mujeres varias
organizaciones feministas han organizado
precisamente esta manifestación para
protestar contra la descripción
unilateral el pasado verano de recep
tayip erdogán de retirar a turquía de la
convención de estambul un convenio
internacional para proteger a las
mujeres de los feminicidos que puedan
perpetrar los hombres dentro de su
familia ya sean sus padres hermanos
novios o incluso maridos muchas
organizaciones se quejan de que turquía
no protege suficiente a las mujeres y lo
muestran así los datos en lo que
llamamos de 2021
353 mujeres han sido asesinadas a manos
de hombres más de una mujer al día así
lo recogen muchos medios turcos y estos
datos no son recabados por el gobierno
que hace años que dejó de recabar estos
datos y lo hacen organizaciones
feministas ellas mismas acusando el
gobierno en muchas ocasiones de
a obviar muchos casos y muchos
asesinatos de mujeres diciendo que son
muertes de los que se conoce la razón y
el motivo estas organizaciones se han
reunido hoy como también lo llevan
haciendo muchísimos días en los últimos
meses y años en turquía pese a que las
manifestaciones feministas son
terminantemente prohibidas por el
gobierno y por la gobernación de
estambul sólo permite el gobierno
manifestaciones que sean propia de recep
tayyp erdogán y prohíbe terminantemente
cualquier otra protesta que sea en su
contra